Even though I walk through the valley of the shadow
of death, I will not fear for you are with me.
You are my light and my salvation.
You restore me and lead me for your glory.
I long to dwell in your house forever.
Well, grace and peace to you church,
it's great to see you.
As always. If you're new to our church, uh,
we are thankful you'd be here.
We'd love to meet you, uh, just to let us know
how we can serve you as well as uh, include you
and connect you as best we can here.
Also, if you've been here at our church
for 60 years, we love you too.
We're grateful that you're here as well.
Now, it may be hard to think about, uh, it is
for me at times, but,
but when was the last time you were truly overwhelmed?
And I'm not saying like that day that you were busy,
but like where you were truly overwhelmed, where
like you, you feel in over your head.
There's no way out where a situation
feels pretty hopeless.
Maybe you've been there before.
I have, and I know many of you have.
It's pretty disorienting, isn't it?
It feels like you just don't even know which way is up
and where to go.
But here's one of the, here's one
of the most painful parts about those times though.
Those kind of emotions
and those kind of feelings are often the ones
that we hide the most at church,
Right?
Like we, we walk in
and we say, well, everything's all together.
I gotta put on the face, I gotta make sure
everybody thinks everything's okay.
But that's why I love the Psalms so much
Because Our tendency is to stuff those things
and put on a brave face.
But the Psalms are honest and raw.
They give us permission to pour out our true feelings
to the Lord even then to others
because we've seen examples of how it's been done.
In fact, today we'll see one of the people
that we portray as like a hero, strong guy in the faith,
somebody who we look at as a tough guy.
We'll see him show his vulnerable side in this psalm today.
And we're gonna just pick up the next Psalm in order
as we've done Psalm 69.
And what we're gonna see King David do today is he's gonna
show us behind the curtain of a life
that's really hard at the time
and struggle, pain, what it feels like
to be overwhelmed with grief, to question God,
to even feel like God's abandoned you.
We'll see it yet my prayer at the same time
is that we also see the God that he points
to in the middle of it.
So God, we do ask you for that, for you to help us see that
as we process and think about true feelings in life
and what that means.
I ask you, Lord, to teach us today,
it's gotta be your spirit teaching us,
your spirit leading us, opening our hearts
and our eyes to understand and see what you want us to know.
It's gotta be your work. God do this
and I pray you would awaken things in us today
that maybe we've stuffed, hidden denied
and you would lead us to you
and heal us today.
God, in Jesus' name. Amen.
So if you're not there already, if you would turn
with me in God's word to Psalm 69,
about in the middle you find the Psalm, Psalms 69.
Now there's a principle of biblical interpretation we
call typology.
Uh, you'll see the word how it's spelled typology.
Now it's related to prophecy that predicts the future,
which you see that in the Old Testament
a lot, even in the New Testament.
But it's unique in that it involves, uh,
events or persons
or even phrases that in a way
in the Old Testament prefigured events around Christ.
So lemme give you an example maybe help you understand.
So Jonah in the Old Testament, he spent three days
in the belly of the fish
and then when the fish spit him out on the shore
where he was supposed to go,
in a sense he was resurrected from the dead.
You might say, well, Jesus picks that same language up
and says, that's kind of like what happened when I was dead
and then raised on the third day, right?
So Jonah is a type of Christ in that sense.
It's even explicit in Romans five 14,
the Apostle Paul calls Adam the first
man in the garden, right?
A type of the one who was to come Christ.
So aspects of Adam's life aligned with Jesus's life
to teach us something.
So we look at Adam, we can study some things
and it teaches us one of the most common types
of Christ, some of the Old Testament.
Prefiguring Christ is King David
and you know King David, the boy with the sling,
the greatest king that Israel ever knew, the one
who wrote many of the psalms that we are studying
through over these decades in this book, right?
In fact, this fall we're gonna continue the study
of David in a different way.
We're gonna look at his kingship
and Saul's kingship in the book
of one Samuel start that in August.
So look ahead towards those things.
But what we're gonna see today in Psalm 69 is this Psalm
presents David's experience as, as the typical servant
who's trying to follow the Lord
that he's in a sense the typical servant you might say,
where he's foreshadowing something
to come in Christ who's the greater king?
That this king is great, the greatest Israel ever knew,
but he's, he's still less than
and he's foreshadowing something to come
in the greatest king Jesus.
So we're gonna see a lot of things about what it means
to be typical, the type here.
But first we're gonna look behind the curtain
of David's life, just verses one through 12 here.
See the struggle again, he's writing this
to the choir master according to lilies,
which is probably some melody line
that they were using at the time.
David wrote this. It says, save me, oh God,
for the waters have come up to my neck.
I sink in deep mire where there is no foothold.
I've come into deep waters, the flood sweeps over me.
I'm weary with my crying out.
My throat is parched, my eyes grow, dim
with waiting for my God.
More in number than the hairs of my head are those
who hate me without cause.
Mighty are those who would destroy me, those who attack me
with lies what I did not steal.
Must I now restore?
Oh God, you know my flia,
the wrongs I've done are not hidden from you.
Let not those who hope in you be put to shame through me,
oh Lord, God of hosts.
Let not those who seek you be brought
to dishonor through me.
Oh God of Israel. For it is for your sake
that I have born reproach.
That dishonor has covered my face.
I've become a stranger to my brothers, an alien
to my mother's sons for zeal,
for your house has consumed me.
And the reproaches of those
who reproach you have fallen on me.
And when I wept and humbled my soul with fasting,
it became my reproach.
When I made sackcloth my clothing, I became a by word
to them, meaning they made fun of me for it.
I am the talk of those who sit in the gate
and the drunkards make songs about me.
That's the struggle. Now,
when we say David is the typical servant, I mean again,
he can be seen as a type of Christ looking forward
to something, but also as the typical servant,
we could see David as a representation of all servants
of Christ of the Lord in a sense He stands in
for all of us.
And so what I did here is from Psalm 69,
picked out just five truths that typify the experience
of a faithful servant of the Lord.
Like what's a servant going to experience, encounter,
feel as they follow the Lord?
There's probably more here you could find,
but I'm just gonna do five today.
So here's the first one. David wrote about it
in verse nine here.
He said He was consumed by zeal for God's house,
servant of the Lord.
He was consumed by zeal for God's house.
Zeal is a word that means passion, devotion
gonna be zealous for a lot of things.
God is even described as zealous in the book
of Isaiah chapter nine.
He brings about the Messiah's light giving kingship, right?
The the typical Christmas passage child is
given, son is given, right?
Like that's what he's doing is he's zealously bringing about
his reign, his rule.
So zeal can be a good thing.
Zeal can show that we're not lazy.
But did you see David was mourning and crying
and fasting because of his zeal for God's house.
But what it led to was he was getting persecuted for it.
People were criticizing him, were coming after him
because he was doing that.
I love, I found this quote from Spurgeon.
He said, zeal for God is so little understood
by men of the world that it always draws down opposition
upon those who are filled with zeal.
They are sure to be check this out.
They're sure to be accused of sinister motives
or of hypocrisy or of being out of their senses.
Like we look at some people like man, they are radical
for Jesus and we kind of think they're a little crazy.
But that's part of it is that zeal can be misunderstood
by people who don't have it.
Which in fact leads to the next point.
David is the typical servant here, right?
And so he's scorned by others for his faith
because of his faith.
He was being scorned all over those 12 verses I read
just a second ago, right?
Innumerable people hated him without cause they were trying
to destroy him.
They were lying about him. They were falsely accusing him.
They were gossiping about him.
Even his family pushed him away
All the way down to verse 12.
He says, the drunkards make songs about me.
If you've ever heard a drunk guy sing, you know
how low David feels, right?
I won't imitate that. I'm not gonna try. Okay,
But That's not even it.
It says in verse 20, reproaches have broken my heart so
that I'm in despair.
I looked for pity, but there was none for comforters.
But I found none like he feels so alone.
In verse 21, they gave me poison for food, for my thirst.
They gave me sour wine to drink.
People even trying to poison him like David is as low
as you can go in this moment.
But don't forget it was all
because he was trying
to serve the Lord that all this came on him.
It was because he was trying to be faithful.
He was zealous for God's house and he was scorned for it.
People came after him.
Now it's easy to, to kind of
project onto these characters things that weren't true.
We'll see that this fall with Saul
and David that we can see both differently.
But before you think David's perfect,
completely innocent in all of it, look again at verse five,
he said, oh God, you know my folly, my foolishness,
the wrongs I have done are not hidden from you.
See, David came humbly to the Lord knowing
that he had actually sinned at some point against God.
He wasn't coming saying, God, I am completely blameless.
Now, he might not have done much of anything
that would've caused what he's feeling to these other people
who were attacking him.
He might not have any guilt there,
but he knew that the God
of the universe could see into his selfish heart.
Now, God, you know, you know my folly.
You know that I'm, I'm wicked still in here.
Even though you've redeemed me, I'm still.
And so what that means, as the typical servant said,
David was disciplined for his sins.
Whether that was true here, like was all of this
directly resulting from his sin?
Probably not. But he knew
because of his sins against God, he was due
and did deserve some discipline, just reality.
So he agreed with the Lord on that,
which is really all that confession is.
Did you know that like when you confess sin,
you're not telling God something he doesn't already know.
You gotta reveal it to him somehow.
Like no, he already knows.
So confession is merely agreeing with God
that you did what you did.
And listen, the fact
that God already knows should grease the
skids of confession.
You shouldn't be afraid of taking it to him
because he already knows it and it's just then on you.
And the burden is lifted as you confess your sins.
And he's faithful and just to forgive us of our sins
and cleanse us from all unrighteousness.
But what we do know whether, whether David's suffering
or our suffering is due to our own sin, which is true.
It happens, right? Or whether it's just from unjust
attacks from other people.
Either way, Romans A says God works for the good of those
who love him and are called according to his purpose.
That's right. So he's gonna turn even the unjust suffering
into something for his glory, for our good.
But I want you to see a key to this.
Notice something else here.
David also knew where to turn in his struggle.
He's feeling the pressure. He's feeling the abandonment.
Where do I turn when I felt the sting of my sin?
Where did I turn when I felt the attacks from others?
Where did I turn? Look at what David did
as the exemplary servant.
He depended on God for his deliverance.
Typical servant example.
Deliverance was from God alone.
What's the first thing out of his mouth in verse one?
Save me. Oh God.
And then feel again the desperation verses one
through three, save me.
Oh God, for the waters have come up to my neck,
meaning he's about to go under all the way
I sink in deep mire, which is like quicksand.
There is no foothold. I can't get out.
I have come into deep waters. The flood sweeps over me.
He's just like all of that's over the top.
I I'm weary with crying out.
My throat is parched,
my eyes grow dim, meaning I grow tired.
I'm weak with waiting for my God.
Many of us read that
and maybe even right now you're like, that's
Me.
Where you can recall a time in your life where
feel like you're underwater, like you're just spinning out
of control, just exhausted from the grief of waiting
and waiting and waiting on God.
But again, where did God turn or where did David turn?
He'd said, save me.
Oh God, save me.
Like if you're drowning
and you know the lifeguard's right there, you're gonna reach
for the lifeguard, right?
Like you know where to turn who can save you.
David knew where to turn,
but people, they were piling on him
and he felt like there was no way out.
I'm drowning. Look at his cry. Look at verse 13.
Start here and we're gonna read
and just listen to his desperate cry here.
But as for me, Like all these people have said all these
things, they're doing all these things for me.
As for me, my prayer is to you, oh Lord,
at an acceptable time, oh God, in the abundance
of your steadfast love,
answer me in your saving faithfulness.
Deliver me from sinking in the mire, right?
Listen for the language that he repeats,
deliver me from sinking in the mire.
Let me be delivered from my enemies
and from the deep waters.
Let not the flood sweep over me or the deep swallow me up
or the pit close its mouth over me.
Answer me, oh Lord, for your steadfast love is good,
according to your abundant mercy, turn to me.
Hide, not your face from your servant.
For I'm in distress, make haste to answer me.
Draw near to my soul. Redeem me.
Ransom me because of my enemies.
See, David never forgot the character of God.
He never forgot that Yahweh that he knew that he loved.
He never forgot him. In fact, he remembered
as the language shows us
what God told Moses all the way back in Exodus 34,
the Lord a God, merciful
and gracious, slow to anger, abounding in steadfast love
and faithfulness, keeping steadfast love for thousands,
for giving iniquity and transgression and sin.
But who will no by no means clear the guilty,
visiting the iniquity, the fathers on the children,
the children's children, the third
and fourth generation, he knew the character of God,
that God Yahweh is a God of salvation.
He knew he's a God of deliverance
and he knew that God was actually near
to him even if he didn't feel like it.
David leaned on his faith on
what he knew to be true over what he felt.
Now we'll see in a moment that David did pray
that God would judge the enemies attacking him.
David did know that God would come through for him
as his child, but David also knew
that it wasn't just for him.
Like I can get kind of selfish.
God save me, deliver me all about me.
David said, no, no, actually there's more to it.
David said the deliverance God that you that I'm asking you
for God give me deliverance.
What I'm asking you for is not only for me, it's also
to bless your people.
God. Psalm 69, starting in verse 29,
he's getting towards the end.
Look at what he says. It says,
but I'm afflicted and in pain.
Let your salvation, oh God, set me on high.
Now that sounds prideful, like show off God through my life.
Notice I will praise the name of God with a song.
I'll magnify him with thanksgiving.
This will please the Lord more than an ox
or a bull with horns and hoofs.
Meaning the sacrifices you can do physically. No, no.
My heart is what he wants. When the humble look at this,
when the humble see it, they will be glad
you who seek God.
Let your hearts revive.
For the Lord hears the needy
and does not despise his own people who are prisoners.
See, it takes maturity to be able to clinging
to those promises even when you're in pain.
But it's not impossible. See that?
You hear that and you're like, there's no way how,
how I suffering so deep.
How could I do that? It only takes a mustard seed of faith.
It only takes the faith of a child.
Jesus says Because a child,
what does a child say? Father, I trust
You.
That's it. Because it's not about the strength
of your faith, it's about the object of your faith.
It's who you're placing your faith in. That's the strength.
And what we see here then is that your testimony
through suffering blesses others deeply.
Right? The humble will see it and be glad.
That's a residual effect of God working in you.
That other people are blessed.
David was not just about himself, he was about others.
But ultimately what we see David searching for,
yes, he wanted deliverance.
Yes, he wanted others to be blessed.
But notice what he was looking to God for.
He was looking to God for his joy. That was it.
That was the main part of this.
Verse three says, he was waiting for his God.
Waiting for what? For joy
in the Meyer, in the flood.
He didn't feel joy. What is he waiting for? He wants joy.
That's why he was consumed with zeal for God's house
because he knew that's where joy was found.
He knew God is faithful.
He knew God would provide everything he ever needed.
And like verse 16 says,
he knew God's steadfast love is good.
It's satisfying, it's joy inducing
when you see God's covenant love for you,
yet here's what he was looking for.
Ultimately that joy to be made complete,
that joy to be made complete in the future when
what we see at the very end
of this psalm would actually come to pass.
Starting in verse 34.
He says, let heaven and earth praise God, the seas
and everything that moves in them for God will save Zion.
That's Jerusalem the hill and build up the cities of Judah.
And people shall dwell there and possess it.
The offspring of his servants shall inherit it
and those who love his name shall dwell in it.
See, that's why David was looking to God for his joy.
'cause he's looking for a joy that cannot be fulfilled here.
And now he's looking for that eternal
joy found in the new heavens
and new earth found when Zion is complete,
when the eternal Zion actually comes to pass one day
and all that God has ordained to happen will be finished
and David knows which we should know.
A future hope like that is
what sustains you through the suffering.
Even today, faith
that God will finish the task
Ask Sustains you today.
And so again, what we see in David is this type ideal
type of a servant.
A template of what someone
who followed the Lord would look like.
He's not the only one. Jeremiah is another example.
Jeremiah longed for the temple.
He was cast off for his faith.
He looked to the Lord for joy
and deliverance while in exile.
Jeremiah is a type of Christ. We see the pattern in Moses.
Moses longed for God's presence in the tabernacle.
He looked to God for deliverance from Egypt.
Even listen to Hebrews 11 says, choosing rather
to be mistreated with the people of God than
to enjoy the fleeting pleasures of sin.
He considered the reproach
of Christ greater wealth than the treasures of Egypt.
For he was looking to the reward.
That's the typical servant.
We see David's pattern, it's shown up even in Moses,
but we see it in ourselves too, don't we?
Like if David is portrayed as the exemplary servant,
then shouldn't there be some similarities in the way we live
our lives as we serve the Lord?
So what does that mean? It
means we ought to be consumed by zeal for God's house too
Ultimately for God's people, God's house.
Now his presence to spend time with him
because not only is he near to us, he's
inside us as believers.
What a gift. We get to have the zeal
for God's house to be with him.
That's what the servant of the Lord would be about.
It means we should experience persecution for our faith.
That that if we're truly living out
what following Christ entails, Jesus said, trouble's coming.
So are we experiencing that maybe we're not living
as faithfully as we could.
It also means we must submit ourselves to the Lord
for his loving discipline in our lives.
'cause none of us are perfect yet.
So as a servant of the Lord, they get disciplined.
That's us. It means we ought
to be dependent on God for deliverance from the things
that we face in our lives,
that we shouldn't trust our own intelligence
or our own resources or our own creativity.
To get out of situations, we need to say, God,
you got this, and trust him.
And it means like David here at the end, we must be looking
to heaven for our true joy to have a measure
of the joy of the Lord both today and for eternity.
That we are satisfied in Him alone, not in here what we see.
So there's a measure of David being a typical servant.
We can learn from that.
But here's the thing about David, Jeremiah, Moses,
all those Old Testament servants, all of each of us today
as well, every one of us, every one of them is a
limited imperfect servant.
Yes, setting a good example at times,
but we're all still tainted.
And so there's, there's one that we have yet to talk about.
A servant of the Lord
Who is the perfect servant whose
Name is Christ.
Yes, David's a great example.
He's the typical servant,
but the one to whom all those others were pointing,
including you and me, is the perfect servant,
Jesus Christ.
See, like we did last week, we can look
to the New Testament to see how it uses this psalm
to help us understand even
what we're reading here in Psalm 69
and thankfully Psalm 69 is one
of the most quoted in the New Testament.
Only Psalm 22 has more quotations.
So what does that mean for us?
Well, it means that Psalm 69 portrays David,
his experience as a type to foreshadow the greater son
that he was going to have what he would endure.
David's the type. And so the way the New Testament uses it
is that that Jesus would endure who's often referred to
by the way, as the Son of David,
what Jesus would endure is actually something
that we can learn from David's
experience and see how it works.
We can also see Jesus,
how he would exemplify the perfect servant of God
that David was limited in doing.
This is why we must read our Bibles as a whole
and here's how Jesus, at least four ways,
how he shows him himself to be the perfect servant
of God for us.
First it's in how Christ was perfect at obeying the Father.
How he obeyed his father.
See John 18 or John 8 29 says, Jesus says,
I always do the things that are pleasing to him.
Hebrews four 15, he was tempted in every way as we are.
Yet he never sinned. He perfectly obeyed the Father.
Plus there's this, this is where we see the, the connection.
You remember the line in Psalm six nine, David said,
I was consumed by zeal for God's house.
Listen to this scene in John chapter two in the New
Testament it says, the Passover of the Jews was at hand
and Jesus went up to Jerusalem.
In the temple he found those who were selling oxen and sheep
and pigeons, the money changers sitting there
and making a whip.
I love this picture of Jesus, right?
He's not just sitting on a rock conditioned hair like he
makes a whip of cords
and he drove them all outta the temple with the sheep
and oxen and he poured out the coins of the money changers
and overturned their tables
and he told those who sold the pigeons,
take these things away.
Do not make my father's house a house of trade.
But listen, his disciples remembered that it was written,
zeal for your house will consume me.
And where did they get that? Psalm 69. Right?
They tied it together.
What Jesus just did in the temple is
what David felt in Psalm 69.
But the, the part that David never saw was that zeal
for God's house would actually consume Jesus
because later those same religious leaders would
come for him and kill him.
That's right. That's the difference.
The perfect servant obeying the Father even unto death.
That's first. We also see Christ
as our perfect servant in carrying our reproach.
This is how Jesus exemplifies a perfect servant.
Remember how David, he struggled
with the scorn of God's enemies.
They were piling it on him. He was suffering for his faith.
We saw it. Psalm 69, verse nine.
He says, the reproaches of those who reproach you,
God have fallen on me.
Well, listen, the Apostle Paul in the New Testament, listen
to how he adapts that and applies it to Jesus.
Romans 15, let each of us please his neighbor for his good
to build him up for Christ, did not please himself,
but as it is written, the reproaches of those
who reproached you fell on me.
Where'd he get that? He got it from Psalm 69.
Because remember, Jesus didn't have to die.
Jesus didn't have to have the reproaches fall in him.
He was sinless. He was perfect.
He did not deserve any reproach.
But not only did he take the unjust ones directed at him
like David did, Jesus also took the just ones
that we deserved and he took it on himself.
The reproaches of those who approach you fall on me.
Not only that, I'm taking all the reproaches
that everyone else deserves.
Second Corinthians 5 21.
For our sake, he made him to be sin who knew no sin, so
that in him we might become the righteousness of God.
That's exactly, He took the punishment.
We deserved the judgment.
The reproaches due us so
that we could be free from all of that.
That's what Philippians chapter two says, one
of the most famous passages about Jesus.
He says, though he was in the form of God,
he did not count equality with God a thing to be held onto,
but he emptied himself, taking the form of a servant,
being born in the likeness of men being found in human form.
He humbled himself by becoming obedient to the point
of death, even death on a cross.
He served you. He served me by suffering our reproach so
that if we put our faith in him, he takes away our reproach.
We don't have to carry our reproaches anymore.
They are all on him.
Now, that's good news,
but there's another major difference here.
Christ, the perfect servant, David, the typical servant
in David's prayer in Psalm 69.
You can go read this all later.
He, he prays curses on his enemies.
I mean, it's things like the middle section of Psalm 69.
Let their table before them become a snare.
Let their eyes be dark
and pour out your indignation upon them.
May there can't be a desolation. Add to them punishment.
Be blotted outta the book of the living.
Those are known as imprecatory prayers.
But what do we do with that?
Like are we free to pray that stuff?
Because some of you're like, I'm thinking
that right now about that guy.
Like, no. Are we?
Are we supposed to pray those kind of things?
Well, this is again where the New Testament helps us
because both Acts one with Judas
and Romans 11 with Israel,
they both quote this part of Psalm 69.
And in both instances, the author uses it against those
who are attacking God, not attacking him.
That it's a a judgment thing that God, you are going
to bring final judgment on your enemies.
That's right. Not God.
Take care of this guy who's making me mad.
It's God. You'll bring justice. Vengeance is God's.
That's why they're quoting it.
Not only that, so that limits us.
But not only that, do you remember how
Jesus handled his enemies?
Like how did Jesus handle those who were coming at him,
those who opposed him as the perfect servant?
He was focused on loving his enemies. Remember that?
Like that's what he taught us in Matthew five.
He says, love your enemies, those who persecute you.
But even on the cross,
he is literally getting attacked, getting made fun
of getting nailed, getting to the cross, getting killed.
He's dying on it.
All of this, he's feeling
this and what did he say?
Like he had just received sour wine.
Like David in Psalm 69, he just received sour.
What did he say on the cross
about his enemies, about those crucifying?
Father forgive them for they don't know what they're doing.
He had every right in that moment to call down curses
and not just like words curses from heaven to wipe them out.
Instead, he said, no, I'm laughing them.
And listen, that's what Jesus did for you
and me as his enemies.
He took the cross. So why can't we do that for others?
We precursors or we love them like Jesus loved us.
And listen, Jesus, this perfect
servant, he did all that.
He did. Obeyed the father, carried our reproach, loved us.
He did it because his mission was securing our eternity.
The perfect servant securing our eternity.
David, the typical servant, was looking ahead to eternity.
Christ, the perfect servant was securing our eternity.
That's the Psalm 69.
The end of it showed us David was looking to God
for his eternal joy, and Christ has secured it for us.
What has he secured?
He secured praised from every nation, every creature.
He secured a permanent dwelling place in the new
eternal Zion.
And it says, for those who love his name,
that's what we've seen today, that those
who love his name
are those who are consumed by zeal for his house.
Those who are willing to face persecution for their faith
with boldness, they are those who look to him
for deliverance and for joy,
and they seek to obey him with everything they are.
Even to the extent of loving your enemies,
those who love his name, do those kinds of things
that David typified, that Jesus perfected.
Why do they do those things?
Because he has carried our reproach
and he has secured our eternity.
That's why we worship the son of David, the perfect
suffering servant.
That's why we worship him.